[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima it is only
episode two of Rachel Lindsay season of
The Bachelorette and already we are
getting the drama drama drama namely
from de Mario and his ex hadn't heard
from him in three days and then suddenly
turned my TV on he took on it
yes de Mario is a contestant who
adamantly said Rachel would be his wife
it's going to be her and I and that's
exactly what it's going to be but Monday
night de Mario's true colors were
seemingly revealed and they were pretty
much in a 180 from what we've been
telling everyone he's my boyfriend of
seven this is de Mario's egg is aptly
named Lexi she came onto the show during
a group date to call Demario help he
lied to all of us and has really
deceived everybody here so Lexi was
ready with her catchphrases Karma's a
[ __ ] isn't at Oriel with her big
reveals he literally still had to excuse
to my apartment and she even had risky I
actually have from the messages proof
callosum you came over and from where
you leaving rachel lindsay has adamantly
said she's going to keep it 100 on the
season of The Bachelorette I just want
to stay true to myself
keep it 100 keep it real and that's
exactly what she did I'm really going to
meet you to give up she sent to Mario
packing but this is not the last we've
seen of jamario next week he make a
return fib gave us security so you can
do it everyone what did you guys think
of Monday night's episode and of how
rachel handled the Demario drama let me
know on Twitter thanks for watching
you